what is up there reject nation star wars
show continues the bad batch
called common ground i think we all have
common ground
we like this show if you clicked on it
because i don't have to say you don't
like it
do something else with your life hey if
you like this show
hit that like button and if you enjoy
our reaction hit that subscribe button
also
wanted to say thank you to all who have
joined us over at our patreon page your
support
is astronomical over there we cover many
shows with the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch along almost done with avatar
don't know why i specifically chose to
plug that one
but here we are today pritham jindal
you're a handsome man
and a skilled editor can only imagine
the ladies swimming over a man who's
that fast with his hands
type them up for thumb type them up
yes what does that mean type up those
ladies with your
super awesome not a typist uh click em
scroll them and scrub them
[Music]
no no recap it's not important let the
past die
the empire is not your enemy
i can't go through with this if you do
not comply with their request you will
be arrested like the other senators
or worse executions such measures were
approved by your esteemed senator avi
singh who would like to say a few words
about the importance of
cooperation compliance gs8
if anything happens to me follow my
instructions to the letter
what will happen turn it up very
discreet you planning something says
senator
fellow citizens i employ to embrace
these new laws and as your senator
i promise i
i promise to you this is wrong
it is my duty to act in your best
interest
and it is why i can no longer
condone this unjust occupation
something's gonna happen to you we shot
no power and then
acts of oppression
we're here to protect you good good old
empire
i'm sending this message on behalf of my
master senator abby singh of raxis
the senator has been seized by imperial
authorities and is in grave danger
destroyed is like the love child of
c-3po and tom from toonami
i wonder who's going to intercept that
message
so when's our next mission with two
bounty hunters after you
it'll be wise to keep a low profile i
never stopped us before
the kid's been through enough she needs
a break
she seems fine to me omega are you
emotionally scarred
i've got a mission for you boys a simple
extraction on raxis
that's simple help a separatist
not gonna happen
your debt's still not paid remember a
job's a job i am not bringing omega to a
planet swarming with imperials
so leave her here with me good idea
i don't exactly trust you either if
anything
happens to her yeah yeah bandana just
get out of here will you
just sleep with her hunter this will
make everything so much easier pay your
debts off
why she's so mean to you is because she
likes you you're staying with sid
but the mission i'm part of this squad
too
then following orders shouldn't be a
problem got it soldier
yes sir good soldiers follow orders
i always thought we'd make a direction
someday
but not like this
[Music]
everything's gonna be fine unidentified
transport this is restricted airspace
transmit your clearance code input the
codes from sits client
how do we know this isn't a trap
[Music]
now are you convinced no
wow the client being a separatist is not
relevant
it is to me forget politics we're here
to do a job
i'm sorry keep your politics out of my
politics who
are you i am your client we're working
for a droid
that is correct my master senator singh
was arrested for speaking out against
the unjust occupation we
don't care just take us to where the
senator's being held
i like you very well follow me echoes on
edge today
those two guys like live at this part
yeah i think so
all right i'll bite what's wrong with
you i haven't heard back from them yet
do you think they're okay they better be
for what this job's been
it's not fair i've got news for you kid
life ain't fair maybe if you weren't so
helpless
those four laser brains wouldn't have
left you here with me
no side
[Laughter]
spin off
there are six exterior guards and
multiple heat signatures inside
we need to take out the compound
surveillance system
move in
i'm into this i love a good
sneaking mission
[Music]
time to make yourself useful you do not
possess a military skill set for a
tactical advantage
we're counting on it you this is a
restricted area
whom are you addressing this is my
master's residence
i suggest you leave before oh dear
stop stop
[Music]
there's two at the door you and omega
loop back around
that would be impossible seeing as omega
is not
on this mission right
not to worry i'm getting i'm omega now
me god i appear to be lost
[Applause]
very good joining the team droid
this antique viles was gifted to senator
singh for his years of service
it is priceless droids droids behave
like jackie chan in a fight scene
delay all you want am i getting out of
this one
i wouldn't do that
hear that we got an expert here
i told you what should i do next
[Music]
it's a strategy game i'm good at
strategy
how good oh great to uh
win a few matches oh great it depends
what's my cat yeah 30 percent
60.
deal yes damn
you know a kid take it all draconian
tactics won't work on me captain bragg
that would be a first captain bragg
hey hey hey it's back
[Music]
senator i followed your instructions to
the letter
i knew you'd come through gs8 an alert
has been triggered
oh here we go our position
has been compromised follow us everyone
is coming
come on seize that tank and blow our way
out of here
how do you intend to gain control of the
armored vehicle from up here
nice
[Applause]
you can't possibly expect me to do that
just don't look down
[Music]
hey wrecker you weren't afraid of
heights yeah i had to be brave for the
both of them
[Laughter]
they've commented one of the walkers
pinned them down walkers
oh no you don't
the rear axle stabilizer is offline we
will need to recalibrate
manually we've been shot in the ass
record i will hold them off
[Applause]
third time's a charm tech how we doing
i need more time
you there
i never much get for that fast i never
prepare for that boss
turn down that alleyway we'll be trapped
in a choke point
you're going to have to trust me
we will lose them very slowly
damn oh
move into position next to that wall
leads to a subterranean passage
titans are going to appear through the
wall
if you don't mind please blast a hole in
the wall right here
cool nice
every time they run that shot of the gun
hurry this way
[Music]
captain the walk is empty
hey you guys did it they pulled off the
mission
you can get paid what am i doing
i cannot abandon my people i must help
them
you will senator but not if you are in
imperial custody
she's right live to fight another day
this guy's not married or anything nope
not family to the people
you think this guy would have like a
family or something
[Music]
what are you doing no one can stop this
kid
of course
i'm adopting you kid you're gonna make
me rich
she's a natural i've never seen anything
like it
i told you to keep a low profile ease up
bandana omega made enough money
to pay off the debt you boys owe me
really
you guys are free you really paid off
our debt
i wanted to be useful oh
no you are useful how about we put those
strategy skills to the test
one match if you win then no more
sitting out on
missions oh you better not cut the
blackett damn show oh you're gonna end
aren't you
don't worry the next episode's going to
be all just the game are they going to
have a rocky 3 ending
freezing no
no i want the one match i wanted to see
damn you show it's gotta leave us one
more
[Music]
john please you're the expert i am the
expert and i was very pleased to see
all of my star wars expectations
represented on screen
of all the canon all of it here
and alive uh no this was a really fun
episode like i think you
pointed out you know you get this sort
of sneaking mission
still like even though there is a lot of
action they don't sneak as successfully
as
other uh you know sneaking missions have
given us still a lot of fun and still
very thrilling and i liked the
uh you know dynamic of the episode
having the main team
going off to do this mission that
involves you know the imperial takeover
and all that stuff and you know the new
separatist movement and all that and
then having this much more contained
story with omega on the other side where
like that
uh in some ways was like even though
it's a lot
more low key and less high stakes like
sort of more surprising because
part of me expected that on the omega
side of the story like some kind of
high stakes or like trouble scenario
would come into play with them
gone and on another mission and whatever
but i really enjoyed what that became
and uh i think as a means of further
developing
what's so special about omega and what
her special capabilities might be i
thought that was a
yeah a lot of fun uh for this episode
but uh what was your uninformed opinion
as a novice to the star wars universe
all right
yeah it was good so it was okay it
wasn't bad yeah you know
it was good you you were able to keep up
and understand what was happening heavy
with information
as long as you weren't lost i just want
to make sure yeah i wanted to say this
was
for me i didn't find it fun it was it
was i was really into it though
i it was uh i had more this like
deliberate pacing about it that i'm not
used to with this show like there's so
much quietness in terms of
sucking you into the fact that they have
to be stealthy on this mission so you
feel that level of like trying to watch
out for the noise you're making
the thought processes underneath the
helmets of these characters when they're
trying to just rescue the senator and
what i appreciate about this one was how
it
like with the action scene it was really
cool
of when they're getting on the tanks you
feel like the
weight it reminded me of like when you'd
see the
machines in pacific rim just feeling
the the motion of them and
the scale and the scope of when they're
going through the city like it's not
crazily choreographed yet it's really
destructive what they're doing to this
city as they're trying to just get the
hell out of there and they have to be
methodical
along the way to get into this one part
of the wall so they can just
sneak out and get through here and then
on a storytelling level
it seemed like they were what they
really did was explore sort of the gray
area of all this
like the imperial the empire they're
very black and white about their thing
even got like this the their troopers
who are like dressed in
white and black and then you have the
bad bats you show up looking all gray
and i feel like that's kind of like a
color representation gray an accents of
actual color yeah
yeah 100 so having that thrown in here
where
you know like the senator being a
separatist
not liking the way the empire is working
even the batch
going are we being set up this whole
time can't trust the droid can't trust a
separatist
come to find out no this guy actually is
all right this guy is actually good
so it did seem to explore this area of
uh of this gray
camp and and again with star wars
sometimes reflecting you know like nazi
germany at the same time
and you you do get a nazi germany
specifically but
uh you know the time of world war ii and
that
opening scene reminds you of like the
harrowing
takes that this the empire take the the
this reminds you of the harrowing nature
of what the empire does
to the people and not just main
characters who we
follow like it's a really distraught
situation
uh of the humans there or not the humans
but just the people on that planet going
we have our rights to be here you guys
don't have your rights yet they're under
their
rule and this leader has
is compelled by the end of like should i
just stay here i can't abandon them but
i have to
leave and strategize to help out so i
actually
thought that there was it was a much
more subtle approach than what i'm used
to seeing with this show
thus far it was quieter in that regard
and a lot more patient even with its big
action set piece which i thought was
visually gorgeous to look at
like i like how just this
like gritty it look you feel like the
oil of everything
yeah you can see how heavy the machines
are and how yeah it's like it's weird
it's
a really compelling action storyline
for the episode but it's not flashy in a
lot of ways
no you know like it does kind of get you
into the grunt work and the difficulty
of
eeking out of a situation like that and
i i really like this stuff
actually with omega and sid back at the
bar like those two guys were [ __ ]
funny
they were funny yeah they're really
funny and that developed in a really
natural pace
you know no i disagree good
finally some conflict for these reviews
yeah no it did and it was the most
appealing i've ever found sid
as well you know getting to see this uh
caretaker quality of her like there's a
fun
cheeky thing about it especially with
omega getting to showcase her strategist
side
and uh earning her way into
demonstrating that and even sid being
the one backing her
up against bandana you know it was a it
was a nice episode this was a really
nice episode with a lot on its mind
more than more than what they even
directly talk about
which is like to me some great visual
storytelling that they did
and yeah i just like the mood and tone
of a good sneaking mission i'm always
really into that
and you expect it to go like a little
bit chaotic i thought the the wrap
up note on it was a little bit like oh
it's over
it's a little abrupt yeah after yeah i
mean it would have been nice if there
had been room
for like a come down instead of like oh
we're back omega's doing great hunter's
a little upset but ah we'll probably fix
this
off screen is the credits rule well i
felt like it should have
could have been a little bit more of a
chase to the ship
and getting away versus we got through
the hole in the wall
all right let's go yeah yeah yeah like
like really fighting down to the wire to
make it out of there versus okay we're
in the woods now it's fine
but i guess it needed to have that
character moment with the senator
and yeah and the droid i thought was
very charming too you know
like even exploring that with the droid
like i hate droids like that's
like that's the way how the attitude was
towards the droid and uh
with like how they were all interacting
with the droid but the droid is learning
this whole time and seems to have the
most heart
in this absolutely yeah it is really
dedicated to
the senator and his mission and yeah
it's like even though
he gives the commander just like follow
my orders to a t it does feel like you
know that the robot
the droid is just you know down for the
cause and down for the mission and yeah
like willing to
even though at first they're like you
know i'm not programmed for any kind of
military strategy but then you know
later on it's like i'm picking it up
you know i'm learning how to do things
yeah it was nice pleasant episode
all right guys what did you think about
it leave your thoughts down below you
can subscribe
click that bell hit that like button and
uh
yeah last but not least let's do it
jn valente jn what
changed the angle that's this is james
valencia jan valente that's right i'm
glad you agree with me because jn
this is important all right you are the
only one who can save
this channel we are in huge debt all
right
and we need you to play on our behalf to
get us
out of the debt the patreon that's a
great start but it's not enough
man and if there's anybody out there who
i think could hold their
own in a hive of scum and
villainy playing a game of strategy in a
wit it's you
jay and valente you probably speak like
every alien language known to the known
universe
all right i only speak this one language
all right so i'm not the guy greg's
definitely not the guy we need your help
jn
so send me a message back all right jan
valencia been years
i just want to know that you're okay
seriously though thanks for still being
here thanks for still being you
and uh hope to hear from you soon make
these so awkward
because that's what the people come here
for